seem to be getting a a lot of the
candidates telling us that uh tax cuts
are affordable and in actual fact pay
for themselves
i think i i actually rather agree with
what robert hayward was saying i think
that the um
the policy content of the hustings has
been extremely disappointing um
it's so superficial it's sound rights
and
the big issues domestically are
obviously a devolution
about which we've heard virtually
nothing
and um
the european situation has been again
the odd sound bites the odd promises to
get it done but you know here we are six
years after the referendum and three
years after a government that set up a
minister to do
and get brexit done uh
all we're getting is more assertions of
getting brexit done
the country is not being asked to face
the consequences of brexit which in my
view are
disastrous but
because of the electoral
system
that they are dealing with what you see
in all the candidates is an
extraordinary caution
because
first of all they've got to try and get
their colleagues in the house of commons
to vote for them but they know that if
they're successful in that there is an
electorate out there which represents a
tiny fraction of a conservative vote a
rather elderly faction and a rather
right-wing faction so
if you're trying to win this battle
you are very constrained in
your ability to widen or deepen the
debate
but we have then candidates as i as i
mentioned in terms of the the offering
on low taxation it's part of that and i
suppose it goes back to the getting
brexit fully done or we're now talking
about um from their point of view the
the opportunities of brexit as they see
it which is the ability to introduce
light regulation
low taxation and a much smaller state
but of course the british public have
shown an appetite for robust public
services and and high spending on those
certainly during the course of the
pandemic
well look
i i fully understand the desire to have
lower taxes
but before i vote for lower taxes i want
to be told what
the body politic is going to cut
who's going to suffer
or the alternative are we just going to
shove the bill onto another generation
more borrowing and
what do we say to all those people with
mortgages who are going to find interest
rates rising and rising even further
because we've actually borrowed more
money when we haven't got it
so
as no answers to these questions emerge
from the hustings yeah look i can say
whatever you like about cut this do that
swap that
but
when i was involved in a debate for the
leadership we didn't have these very
superficial contests what we had was an
in-depth discussion with qualified
journalists one-on-one so you've got a
much deeper probing into what people
what john and douglas and i actually
believed and there was another advantage
about that is that if i have one memory
of that particular
election in 1990 it is not a bitter word
from one end of it to the other and so
when we all joined john's government
the media the result was over there was
no bitterness
there's no feeling oh god you know i'll
get him or anything like that we we went
in as colleagues and as friends and and
remained so throughout the period of the
government
and lord hesseltine staying with that
experience extensive experience of
government at the very highest levels
i mean you governed through at least two
severe recessions it seems we could be
facing yet another one certainly some
severe economic difficulties
do you see any of the candidates now
facing up to that reality and perhaps
having the qualities to take us through
them
well look
let's deal with that second part of the
question
those are the candidates we've got one
of them is going to be prime minister so
get used to it but the question is are
they facing the truth to the british
people
and i have to say that i i don't think
britain is being told the truth about
first of all
the disaster of brexit the uh
a million people have gone
home we've got endless
empty
jobs we've got shortages we've got
queues
and the desperate need for people to
fill them and there's no
reason to believe that that's going to
be magicked into a solution
um
we have
a very serious inflationary problem we
have borrowing at levels that are
frightening we have the prospect of
interest rates going up and therefore
even more pressure on people and the
truth of the matter is
that no government can actually do more
than tinker at the fringe of this
problem the british people are going to
see a serious reduction in their living
standards over the next 12 months and
there's nothing any government can do to
avoid that except
tinker at the edge
and that will not change public opinion
and do you have a preferred candidate
lord hesseltine
ah
look i have a reputation on certain
issues and the last thing i want to do
is to prejudice anybody's choices by
putting my name alongside theirs
lord hessentine always good talking to
you thank you very much indeed thank you
michael that's the time there with his
analysis of the challenges facing the
next prime minister which we'll learn
more about in four or five minutes time
uh just to tell you if you scan the qr
code on your screen you can see it there
you can listen to today's sky news daily
podcast
well our deputy political editor sam
coats has been speaking to a clutch of
conservative mps about boris johnson's
time as prime minister and his legacy
you can subscribe to the daily podcast
wherever you get your podcasts from
so uh five or six minutes to go until we
get the results there in that committee
room the chair of the backbench 1922
committee sir graham brady if you've
been following the previous two ballot
results you'll be aware how it's done
here alongside the committee of the
1922. come out very briefly and announce
in alphabetical order the number of
votes cast for the five candidates at
the end of that process uh the candidate
with the lowest number of votes will be
eliminated there he was originally a
hurdle of at least 30 mps that's gone
just however has the fewest votes from
their fellow mps will go then there will
be four will our political editor beth
rigby uh anticipating that result is in
parliament's central lobby right now so
uh beth set the scene for us
well dharma this is uh the third round
in this leadership ballot we should have
the answer of who is going to be in the
final two
within the next 48 hours but my goodness
it's going to be one hell of a battle
before then what are we looking for
tonight well there's a wide expectation
here that tom tugan hat will get knocked
out tonight he
lost votes in the last round he went
from 37 to 32 so we're looking to see if
he'll bleed
more votes tonight will uh some of them
go over to penny mordant to try and give
her a boost tonight so tom tougenhart
expected
to be knocked out tonight but then what
else are we looking for well
sawela bravaman you know she got knocked
out in round two she has 27 votes she
has publicly endorsed his trust and
asked her backers to get behind the
foreign secretary so we're looking to
see where liz trust can go tonight has
she got momentum i spoke to one person
on her camp in her camp earlier today
and they said at these later stages it's
really important that liz trust shows
momentum it matters now in these final
ballots as to where she's picking up the
votes and they hope that they'll see
some momentum from their candidate
tonight but watch too
to see how kemi badanok does does some
of the braverman votes split for her she
was on 49 votes
in the last round liz trust i think was
on 64 from memory or 65 and then penny
mordant out ahead of them at 83. what
about rishi sunak he was on
101 i'm told from those in his camp uh
that he's not expecting to make many
gains uh tonight given uh that sweller
bravo man's supporters are not likely to
break for rishi sunat but can he tick up
to that 120 mark that's the magic number
that you need to get into the final two
so all exciting here to see how it
breaks out tonight liz trust will be
looking for momentum penny mordant will
want to hold second position uh rishi
sanat will want to put on some votes uh
and what happens with kemi badanok it's
all very unpredictable it's all very
exciting uh and i can't wait to find out
the results actually well not long to
wait beth beth how has the the bad blood
which we saw exhibited in some of the
television debates how has that been
playing out amongst the electorate i.e
conservative mps
yeah there has been uh some real blue on
blue uh infighting in this increasingly
bitter uh divide between the candidates
really taking shot and aim at each other
last night in that itv
uh debate which
why does it matter well for other
cabinet ministers to criticize
colleagues or to criticize their
economic policies
it really is quite damaging for the
government more widely to see
colleagues publicly denouncing
policies and strategies of the
government that has been as we know
in power for the past 12 years so it's
been pretty unpleasant i think that
behind the scenes uh some candidates
have been asking uh their supporters to
dial it down a bit but i have to say
dermot this is a bitter battle the party
is riven by divisions you're seeing it
playing out
in some of the hot shots that candidates
are taking at each other and it's not
going to ease off because once they get
through
this final round whoever's in the
run-off they've got another
few weeks of campaigning
where they're going to go around
hostings and have to put different
versions of conservatism and their
vision for the future
to members of the party in order to try
and secure enough votes to become the
prime minister so i don't think this
blue on blue fighting is going to end
any time soon
okay beth i'm going to pause it there
because it is approaching eight o'clock
and uh normally sir graham brady
certainly in the previous two rounds has
been
right on time with his announcement as
it turns eight o'clock i will uh welcome
news viewers to sky news who are just
joining us are all our eyes on that
committee room in the heart of the
houses of parliaments where we awaits
the chairman of the 1922
back bench committee sir graham brady to
emerge with the results of the third
round of balloting of conservative mps
on who should replace boris johnson as
leader of the party and therefore become
the prime minister
five mps five candidates left in the
race uh led by rishi sonak the former
chancellor
in second place after the second ballot
penny mordent trade minister liz trusts
the foreign secretary on 64 and kenny
baidenock on 49 tom two manhattan on
i have the results of the third ballot
uh 357 votes were cast out of a possible
total of 358 i'll again read the name of
the candidates and the number of votes
cast
in alphabetical order
uh vadernock
58
mordent 82
sunak 115
trusts 71
toughness 31.
so tom tougandat is eliminated from the
election
the other candidates are able to go
forward to a fourth ballot which will
take place tomorrow between 1 and 3 p.m
with the results announced at 4 p.m
thank you very much
well there we are the results of the
third round of polling in the
conservative leadership race and
very very interesting indeed rishi sunak
has increased his share of conservative
mps from 101 to 115 penny mordent
stays in second place but actually
lost one vote she's now on 82 having
achieved 83 in the previous round list
trusts has gone up by seven from 64 to
71. kemi begnocker has gone up by nine
from 49 to 58. tom tugan had lost
another vote
just above 30 which had been the hurdle
to pass not anymore if you finish bottom
you're out and as you can see there tom
tugan hat is ejected as announced by sir
graham there and the next round the
fourth round of polling it's pretty
relentless this now until they get down
to the last two will take place between
one and three tomorrow after noon with
the result announced at 4 pm so make a a
note of that for the next stage of this
fascinating race let's get reaction uh
again from our political editor beth
rigby so beth i mean rishi sunak they're
continuing to to build just below the
120 that would have got him through
automatically but penny mordent
dropped a vote
yeah look down but what's interesting
about these results is the person who's
showing the most momentum is actually
rishi sunak and given that it was sawela
bravaman who was on the right of the
party in arch brexiteer uh not
necessarily the sort of backers uh that
would fall into the rishi sunak column
his team will be very pleased with that
now he's just five votes off getting to
the final two
tom tugan had eliminated again he lost a
vote uh so he didn't put any on he
didn't lose loads though but he's
eliminated but as you said uh dermot
penny mordant you know you didn't expect
penny morden really to pick up votes
from sweller braveman either but for her
to lose a vote here that is not showing
the momentum that her team would want
and she will be disappointed with that
she will be hoping to recover with some
tom tugan heart hat votes coming her way
but then liz trusts too i mean liz truss
if this is a moment of momentum she's
put on seven votes kemi badanock did
better than that she's put on nine votes
so kemi badanok actually doing better
there than liz trust so really now you
have morden and trust really slogging it
out for that second spot neither of them
will be particularly happy with that
performance liz trusts slightly closing
the gap on penny morden but there's
still
11 votes
between them and let's see where the tom
tugan hat votes go in the next round
because as one of morden's supporters
said to me earlier today they think that
they will split between rishi sunak and
penny morden if that happens rishi sanak
is pretty much now nailed on for the
final two and it's going to be an
absolute vicious battle between uh
mordant and liz truss to get through and
in fact can i carry on dermot because
i've got george freeman here uh who is
on penny morden's team where'd you want
me to go alex shall i go
if you could go there george let me move
around sorry are we
oh ian do you want to come on as well or
do you want to come on to get okay let's
just sorry okay um george penny's
dropped to vote you must be really
disappointed no i think she's hell
doesn't she but she's in she's dropped
to vote she's gone backwards but after
the three days pounding she's had in the
media i'm to be honest i'm delighted
that she's held second place i mean
nobody has been attacked so savagely in
the last three days in in the tory press
than penny more than and her support is
strong i think the story tonight is
actually kenny badenock
is becoming the heroine on the right
she's picked up a lot of votes and i you
know she's picked up nine votes and liz
has picked top seven and tom touganat is
out and i think what you'll see now is a
lot of that one nation support base for
tom toughenhart a great man i helped set
up the one nation caucus i think a lot
of them will come to penny as the one
nation compassionate conservative george
to be honest it's not just the attacks
on penny she's not had a great weekend
has she she's been pretty lackluster in
the debate she's not really
impressing in the way that she needs to
keep momentum
i don't think so i think if you look at
the two debates i thought particularly
the second last night
the first she was in the teeth of a very
very big media storm but i thought last
night she was very powerful the polling
suggested that she's still leading key
point in the marginal seats around the
country and down in the southwest in the
northern red wall seats around scotland
northern ireland she's presented herself
as a unity candidate to stop the
squabbling she's cabinet grade but a
fresh face i think there's a lot more
support for benny morton in the country
than this vote reveals just final
question george she's got 82 tom's got
31 votes even if she picks up all of
tom's votes which she won't she hasn't
got enough to get to the final two and
bad enoch votes are not going to break
for penny morden are they i mean bad
enoch has made it really clear in all
the debates that the person she really
doesn't want is penny mordan
well i don't know um that you're right
about that necessarily beth i think
there's a very fluid vote the days where
each person carried all their supporters
is long gone i suspect that tom
touganavo will come strongly over to
penny as the one nation brexiteer and i
think penny and tom on a ticket together
would be very real and very authentic
quite a lot of conversation if you had
any conversations with tom tugan has the
team has the team i haven't uh penny's
talking to all candidates i know but i
think a lot of you trying to do a deal
with him now there are lots of
conversations going on but kenny's
supporting that's a yes have said to me
kemi supporters have said listen uh you
know we want change thomas said we want
change well you can't have liz trust and
rishi sunak i think rishi is clearly the
class act he's up there as the one to
beat we're now fighting for the second
ticket and i think penny morgan is the
obvious person she's a woman she's an
authentic brexiteer unlike liz trust
she's an enterprise story she's run her
own business she's strong on defense she
can pick up the international brief and
i think she and rishi would be a very
strong ticket this summer it's been a
tough 48 hours isn't it
very tough um i for your viewers
probably i hope it's fun to watch it's
not much fun being in it but we're
fighting here over something very
important the heart and soul of the
future the conservative party and penny
mortens is fighting for a positive
aspirational liberal britain for a
post-brexit britain that goes forward
not back all right george freeman thanks
so much thanks for coming on sky news uh
so there you have it the verdict from
george freeman who is backing penny
mordant he thinks dropping one vote is
okay hoping to pick up more votes from
tom toughenhart the sense i get is
obviously trying to do a deal uh with
tom tuggenheart see if he can get him
onto penny's team she's going to have a
hell of a battle to get through to the
final two it's going to be a real race
between her and liz trust neither of
whom really are breaking away from each
other right now the only winner really
in all of this tonight i would say is
rishi sonak he's now five votes off the
match at 120 to get through to the final
two hi beth thanks so much for the
analysis our political editor beth rigby
there in parliament's central lobby well
after that vote let's just remind you of
the next steps in the conservative
leadership race as beth was saying there
um the votes are coming thick and fast
now over the next two days to whittle it
down to the final two so tomorrow a
fourth round of voting you heard sir
graham brady announced that 3 p.m
between one and three voting closes at
three uh the announcement will be at
four o'clock and that will take us down
if somebody hasn't pulled out already to
three then on wednesday the last round
of mps voting will produce the final two
candidates then on thursday mps break
for the summer holidays the
parliamentary recess and it's then over
to the parties uh 200 000 members or so
to select the winner the next prime
minister will be named on september the
5th when parliament returns from that
recess
and of course the leadership contest
certainly feature in tomorrow's papers
alongside the weather we'll have our
press preview and news review at half
past 10 this evening with tonight's news
and tomorrow's headlines joining us will
be the political editor of the daily
mirror pippa crera and the home affairs
editor with the times matt dathan
okay well we'll get more reaction to uh
that result rishi soon like just uh five
votes short if you get 120 mps
supporting you you are automatically
through to that uh next round the round
when uh the membership of the
conservative party uh decide who is
going to be the next leader richard
nikon
115 or the other candidates still below
a hundred uh let's look at the day's
other news now and of course
the temperatures affecting most of the
united kingdom still extremely high
and are going to remain so overnight
after much of britain enjoyed day one of
the first ever red extreme heat weather
warning the uk record was nearly broken
and a new one was set for wales the
runway at luton airport was affected by
the heat grounding all flights and
causing many others to be diverted for
several hours and a 16 year old boy
became the fourth person in this heat
wave to die after drowning in a lake in
berkshire well this is where the
temperatures peaked in the uk today in
england the hottest temperature has been
recorded in santander in suffolk 38.1
degrees just over half a degree off the
all-time record
wales recorded its hottest day since
records began 37.1 degrees recorded at
hardin airport in flincher
in scotland temperatures hit 31.3
degrees in aberdeenshire
and northern ireland had its hottest day
of the year so far temperatures rose to
31.1 degrees in derry lynn in county for
mana
now uh let's get more uh on that uh
third round of voting in the
conservative party leadership contest as
i was just telling you rishi sunaka the
clear leader uh our political editor
beth rigby as you know is in
parliament's central lobby with uh a
former leader beth yes dumb that's what
i've got ian duncan smith with me who's
back in uh liz truss ian that's not
quite the momentum is it that you needed
tonight i mean a bit disappoint
i mean zwella braveman came over to liz
trust she urged her backers to support
her 27 votes up for grabs liz took seven
i mean that's that's that's bad well
it's not bad at all this is all about
momentum liz trust has gone forward
penny has stalled and gone backwards uh
kevi's gone forward as well but the
point is that hold on a second you've
got to understand how these things work
what happens is in this round those that
go forward will be the ones that benefit
in the next round
and liz is definitely in that she's in
prime position to do that because there
are still a lot of votes sitting there
that likely to come to liz at some point
once this is settled you would have
preferred her to do a bit better than
that come on no no i i'm very i'm
completely content as to where she is
she's gone forward she's content but not
really happy no because this round is
about moving day for tomorrow in other
words people make their final decision
about who they really want to take
through to the final round tomorrow
because there are still now four people
in this race
can be bad or not put on more votes than
liz trust a lot of people went to kemi
because they wanted to stop penny now
they have to make a decision as to who
they want to vote for maybe they prefer
cami to liz you'll always get this this
is a competition just in case you hadn't
noticed
and liz is the one that is still out
there in third place she's had real
momentum going forward and the reality
is all the others are now trailing her
and interestingly penny has made no
progress and that's a very big part of
this so there's momentum for liz she'll
do well tomorrow when this all starts to
form what's your message to those that
are backing kemi badanok over liz trust
my view is very simply this it's time
for them to come together with liz and
to get on
so that liz ends up on that final round
uh whether it's against rishi or penny
or anybody else it's really time for us
to establish that position because at
the moment what's happening is the votes
are dividing across to people but liz
has got the momentum she's in third
place and she will maintain that
momentum tomorrow
penny morgan's camp would argue that
given that it was bravo man that dropped
out and she is on the right of the party
that she is a candidate where those
votes would always break for trust
indeed swallow brotherhood publicly
backed trust whereas now tom tugan has
out a one nation conservative that's
going to benefit penny going into the
next round isn't it i wouldn't make too
many observations people vote for
different reasons you say come on ian
come on i mean i've done seven of these
all right i don't think you have i've
run two campaigns i've run two campaigns
and i fought one and one one myself okay
so let's be very clear i do know what
i'm talking about on this the key is
that you have momentum going into this
particular round before you get to the
final two rounds momentum is critical
you have to have that and liz has got
momentum yes kemmy got votes as well and
she's got some momentum but the key test
now is who is in third place and that is
liz trust this is a very important place
to be for this contest
and penny is stalling so this is still
open and i believe liz is in the right
place to do this this round was always
about maintaining your position with
some momentum she's done that and then
for the next round when you see it
breaks again
it's time to make those decisions about
who you want to go in the second round
and i believe that kemi's team will come
over to liz just finally then your
message to kemi badnot supporters
tonight is please come over to liz in
the next round if you want to stop
morden i'm not begging anybody to do
anything i'm simply saying to them they
have to make a decision about who they
want to go into that round at the moment
rishi sunak is in the lead although he
still hasn't made it
across the line which we were told he
would do with ease but
it now is up to them
as to whether or not they want liz and
ko to go across into that place that
fights the election in the country ian
final question are you 100 sure that um
your candidate will make the final two
absolutely that's why i'm supporting her
she's the only one that's got the
credentials in government
the nature of what she's done what she's
done for
ukraine and also for the northern
ireland protocol all the trade deals she
delivers in government so i want her to
go through because it's her record that
impresses me ian thanks so much for for
joining us on sky news um derma if
you'll indulge me i've also got mark
harper here if
if i could have a quick word with him he
of course is a former uh chief whip
himself and is on team team sunak um
mark your guy's nearly over the line
well i think that was a good result for
us today this was this was potentially
our most difficult ballot because
obviously the candidate that got knocked
out last week swella bravaman given her
her particular pitch that she was making
to colleagues we didn't really
anticipate getting very many if any of
her supporters so to to go up by 14 uh
the biggest jump of any of the
candidates today i think it's a very
solid result for issue i suspect it's
because we've had two debates now
colleagues will have looked at those
debates they'll have seen a man across
the detail ready to be prime minister um
and able to take us to a general
election victory in two years time after
a period of solid competent government
and i think that's why they'll have
support i mean he now looks pretty
nailed on to get to the final two that's
fair isn't it well we're not going to as
we've done all the way through we're
optimistic but we're not going to take a
single thing for granted we're going to
work for every vote from every colleague
between now and wednesday but look the
results so far are very promising mark
when you look at the results in the
round
ian duncan smith they're saying that liz
has momentum she's put on seven votes
kemi badanok put on nine penny mordent
dropped back one how's it shaking out
the wider race well look i think i'll
let other candidates make the particular
remarks about their own candidates
performance but if you look at where the
votes went rishi was up 14
that was stronger a stronger performance
than any other candidate
at a time when the votes that were freed
up by uh zuella exiting the contest were
very unlikely to come his way so i think
a very solid performance i think based
on those fantastic performances in the
two debates he's going to keep making
his arguments to colleagues uh i hope we
get a really good result tomorrow and
also on wednesday okay well look thank
you very much um thank you i think
uh dermot if you don't mind i've also
got anne-marie trevelyan here who was
instrumental in tom tugan hat's campaign
he's he's gone
yes we are sad to see tom go out but he
has been able to present a fantastic
both policy agenda and for the country
and of course our tory mps and members
to get to know him better a man with
incredible integrity leadership skills
and he will be part of the future of the
conservative party i know it's been
lovely to see both him and indeed kemi
set out that vision the next generation
if you like of the conservatives values
and ideals and i know that overnight tom
will consider where we as a group want
to go he will want those group want
those
votes that we bring to be
with the candidate who is most likely to
support his policy agenda praise for
kami badanok as well as tom tugan heart
there but no praise for
the woman that actually works for you in
your department penny morden
so all the candidates bring their own
fantastic qualities and i think anyone
who's willing to set themselves up to
standards uh prime minister of kansas is
incredibly brave and has enormous
respect from me and i look forward to
seeing both how we progress this as mps
this week but then also sending the two
to the to the country and i know that
that's really important because there we
get what you might call uh the common
sense that uh regional variations
certainly my members have been sending
messages to me and they are not all the
same many have been very supportive of
tom but many see others particularly
rishi as adversaries on the radio though
this morning i think i'm right in saying
that you'd made a remark that often in
your department penny was nowhere to be
seen when decisions were having to be
made and other people had to pick up her
work
so the issue i raised i was asked on lbc
this morning uh whether i agreed with
lord frost's assessment uh and what i
set out was that uh there had been a
number of issues i've always said beth
that i would never ever lie as a
politician i always want to give a
straight answer if you ask me a straight
question i will always do my best give
straight answer and therefore the answer
was uh i would agree lord frost in that
there have been times over the last few
months where penny has not been able to
meet some of the issues which were her
departmental uh
remit if you like and we have therefore
had to backfill with our nemesis i am
completely respectful of the fact that
any minister does their work in their
own way we are all mps first and that's
really important really important so
where we have other constituency
pressures and indeed other issues that
are important to us ministers fit their
whole portfolio together that's really
important to understand but it has been
the case and i answered the question
honestly that uh in the last few months
there have been a number of times when
penny has not been able to pick up what
would have been her departmental duties
so just to be clear um
the lord frost those sort of issues
around competence
they do
resonate with you about penny morden so
the challenge is only in our case in in
dit has been that she has uh in a number
of situations not been available to take
up the the work that was required in a
number of ways be it visits or and be
parliamentary duties okay so you won't
back her in the next round
uh we will tom and tom and the team we
will be traveling i think as a pack
so we will look very closely i think
mostly at the policy areas it's really
important to tom and to all of us that
those key areas thinking about what the
prime minister has called leveling up
and what tom thinks of as that
reaching out to every talent city in the
country and the importance of that uh
union commitment tom's passion for the
union is one that i think we all feel
alongside him it's my summary is that um
penny mordant is sort of has positioned
herself as a one nation conservative as
has tom tougan had so if you look across
the remaining candidates you might think
policy wise uh politically penny might
be the most natural
uh the natural uh successor to tom in
terms of the values of the party is that
fair so i think has set out an
incredibly detailed uh and broad-ranging
policy agenda uh and other candidates
have uh done that to a lesser grace
degree so it will be for all of us to
think overnight after we've had a nice
cool drink because it is very hot here
in westminster this evening to think
about where uh we feel and who we feel
is the right candidate for us uh to take
through to the next round of course
that's just the next stage then we'll
have another one and then it'll be up to
the members to decide thank you so but
thank you for for taking some time to
talk to me sorry dermot um hogging the
show there apologies but they everyone
came at once so that's um anne-marie
trevelyan there i mean repeating uh what
she said earlier today that there were
some issues around competence uh with
penny morden in her department she's the
secretary of state penny morden uh one
of her ministers so that's hardly an
endorsement there from anne marie
trevelyan saying there that tom tugan
hat and his group band of followers 31
of them haven't yet decided uh where to
put their vote mordant will hope to pick
some up so too will sonnack i imagine
that sonnet will be through to the final
two uh in the round tomorrow
all right beth
much more to discuss then thank you very
much indeed sterling work
our political editor between be there in
the heart of parliament in the central
lobby let's just take you through if you
are just joining us or haven't fully
absorbed it all the results of the third
round ballots of conservative mps in the
conservative leadership race well there
we have the ins and the outs there were
five going into today's ballots uh at
the bottom finished tom tugan had he got
31 votes one fewer than he actually got
in the second round he's therefore
ejected just for simply having the
lowest number of votes the other results
set kemi bagnock on 58
going up then liz truss on 71. penny
mordant on 82
the front runners then penny mordent and
rishi sunak 115 but interestingly penny
more than they're on 82 is down one from
the 83 she garnered in the second round
rishi sunak on 115 is 14 more than he
got in the second round the magic number
to
be guaranteed to make it through into
the final two is one hundred and twenty
so rishi sonak just five
short of that going into the fourth
round tomorrow voting taking place
between one o'clock and three o'clock
the results announced at four just five
short of hitting 120 and therefore
making it through in to the final two
then the gloves are off between the
other three to join him if it should be
rishi sunak making it across the line
first
you're watching sky news tonight coming
up more on the extreme heat including
how it is connected to the climate
emergency
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
it's really desperate that is actually
the sort of
pretty much hopeless column
[Music]
we saw snatch was going in grabbing
people
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a walk that's the
way
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked where we're right
well enormous explosion has just come
down
it's not out of control but withdrawn
it's oh so hot
[Applause]
[Music]
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie ridge on sky news
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
some breaking news concerning the
weather and a 14 year old boy is missing
and believed to have drowned after
swimming in the thames in richmond today
police were alerted by the london
ambulance service to reports that a
child had been seen entering the water
at tanks island in hampton and earlier
today a 16 year old boy became the
fourth person to die in this heat wave
after drowning in a lake in berkshire
well our technology and science editor
tom clark has been looking at events
nationwide on a day that saw
temperatures peak
in this heat fire is almost an
inevitability a blaze at licky hills in
worcestershire has covered nearly half a
square kilometer with four fire crews
working to stop it spreading more
further south it's been hotter still
with temperatures exceeding 38 degrees
in some places
cambridge holds the uk heat record set
here in 2019
it was only a degree below that today
the local museum has opened its doors to
allow visitors some respite from the
heat that this town never experienced
before the 21st century
it feels like a wall of heat is it nice
to be in here out of the heat
yes
it is
in the surrounding countryside they were
harvesting in the early hours but in
this heat they're heading in
the wheat is so dry they're losing
around 50 pounds on every hectare
gathered
already some parts of the uk have seen
temperatures higher than they have ever
seen before and with climate change
pushing up average temperatures
heat waves like this are only becoming
more frequent and they continue to do so
in future that's already changing the
way we live and how we work
i've been working on the farm about 12
years in my mind harvest finishes at the
end of august beginning of september
but actually more and more recently
we've been having it finishing in early
august it's not out of the question this
year that we'll finish in july already
in the last few years we've seen things
changing significantly
extreme heat like this is driven by
large scale weather patterns but average
temperatures are set to continue to rise
for decades increasing the risks
in our climate here in the uk there is a
place for enjoying fine summer weather
but situations like we're experienced
this week is not that case
so this is a severe and extreme weather
event that people need to take action
and respond to and climate change is
making this type of weather more likely
to occur
in stockport volunteers were taking food
parcels to those advised not to venture
out in this potentially deadly weather
thank you very much
walters today yeah thank you okay thanks
very much really hot
extremely hot unbearably hot to be
honest also i've got walks i can't can't
really walk very far so i'm like i'm
pretty much isolated in it so i'm just
sitting in the stifling heat to be
honest
a boy of 16 died after getting into
difficulty in bray lake near maidenhead
in berkshire the fourth person to drown
in the heatwave so far
calls to london ambulance service were
already up 30 due to last week's heat
not surprisingly they're seeing even
more calls now
extra resource has been put in place the
contingency plans that are well
established have been activated
and we're meeting uh regularly with nhs
leaders with ambulance chief execs to
closely monitor the impacts and
particularly the handover
times so we can mitigate those with the
increased pressure they're facing
even after sunset it's expected to
remain close to 30 in many places an
uncomfortable night ahead of tomorrow
when temperatures are forecast to exceed
40 degrees
bringing a new chapter to the uk's
climate history
tom clark sky news cambridge here
and this is sky news tonight coming up
are we about to start seeing heat waves
like this one far more often
and why a new book about harry and megan
is threatening to overshadow the work of
the prince as he gives a speech to the
united nations
[Music]
you're watching sky news tonight the top
stories this hour and the uk has
experienced its first day of a red
extreme heat warning with temperatures
reaching more than 38 degrees
a new record was set in wales for its
hottest day ever with a temperature of
37.1 degrees in hardin in flincher
and wildfires are burning in spain
portugal and france temperatures have
exceeded 42 degrees in some places
[Music]
well one economics expert told sky news
today that the uk needs to change how it
thinks about itself and that it is no
longer a cold country while this week
might feel exceptional a rise in
baseline global temperatures could see
phenomena like this one occurring much
more regularly our climate correspondent
hannah thomas peter reports now on how
the heat wave is connected to the
climate emergency
reading university's atmospheric
observatory they have been measuring the
temperature every day at 10 am since
1908.
there are few places better equipped to
track what's happening as climate change
drives increasingly frequent and severe
heat events
and then there's also another one over
there researcher chloe brimikum tells me
that rising baseline temperatures are
magnifying the intensity of heat waves
with trapped high pressure air and drier
hotter ground driving a feedback loop
that acts like an oven
by